I'm back did you miss me it's good to be
back I have been banned from YouTube for
a week
because I made a very basic statement
about human nature that has always been
true and remains true today but I've
Been Told
we're not allowed to talk
about that certain issue that's on
everyone's Minds what is a woman
um
yeah
on the minds of men
on the minds of women on the minds of
people who were a little bit uh
uncertain or maybe
have a particular
unconventional views on which one of
those things that they are so we've been
told by YouTube you're not you're not
allowed to
publicly hold the opinion
on a certain issue
that everyone virtually for all of human
history has ever believed
and and so the only opinion you're
allowed to have on that particular
political issue on YouTube is a lie and
so I'm not gonna lie
I'm not gonna lie for YouTube I'm not
gonna lie for anybody nobody can make me
lie so if you want to catch the full
show with all of my commentary on
certain issues that you're not allowed
to talk about on YouTube you'll have to
go to Delaware plus and you can check it
out on Twitter too at M Knowles show we
are now posting my full episode over
there but we've had a whole week of
shows here and our producers
have found the very finest
highlight reel of the stuff we're
allowed to say on YouTube
to present to you right now I've missed
you
it's good to be back things are not
looking great for Trump
from a legal perspective right now
the reason for that is
not just the crime that they're alleging
that Trump committed
not just the quality of the crime but
the quantity they are throwing the
kitchen sink at this guy
dozens of counts against Donald Trump
why because if even one of them sticks
as Jonathan Turley the
often pro-trump law professor and legal
analyst points out the man could die in
prison the problem is that he's got to
run the table he's 76 years old all the
government has to do is stick the
landing on one count and he could have a
terminal sentence uh you're talking
about crimes that have a 10 or 20 year
period as a maximum the evidence here is
quite strong now we haven't heard their
other side I've you know generally these
indictments are a lot stronger on the
day they're issued than the next day so
they may be able to knock down some of
these issues but some of this evidence
is coming from his former Council and
these are very damaging statements that
have made against him it may be hard to
move those the fact is both things may
be true yes the Department of Justice
may have been out to get him but he made
it easy I mean if you look at what is
being described in this indictment
confront it with someone that he felt
was trying to get him he couldn't have
made it more easy for them to do so
you made it easy and maybe he did
maybe he did
Donald Trump is not one to go along to
get along to be pushed around to slap
backs and cozy up to the political
establishment and wait his place in line
that's not what Trump does that's not
why he got elected that's not how he
became famous that's
just not in the guy's bones
and so Turley
who has long defended Trump says yeah
maybe the doj's out to get him but maybe
he made it easy for them to get him okay
but I don't really care about that last
part
because they would have gone after him
for something they would have indicted a
ham sandwich if that ham sandwich's last
name was Trump
they've been trying to get him on
completely spurious charges totally made
up in some boardroom at the FBI or
actually more likely in the Clinton
campaign
since 2016
and now maybe they get him because he
moved a box of documents from one room
to another
Joe Biden
keeps keeps documents all over the place
underneath this Corvette where his
degenerate son degenerate seems to be
the word of the day
because it describes our ruling class
Joe Biden keeps these documents in
multiple States
going back to his time in the Senate
when he had no no right to to declassify
this on a whim
nothing happens Hillary Clinton has
contemporary classified information on a
server easily hackable
no consequences whatsoever so I
appreciate Jonathan turley's analysis
I'm sure he's right
but I don't want to hear this from any
of Trump's Advocates I certainly don't
want to hear this from any Republican or
conservative who's trying to figure out
what we do now about this case I don't
want to hear well you know they might
have gotten him
no
you know when Trump said I could shoot a
guy in Fifth Avenue and and I wouldn't
lose one vote I'm basically there at
this point and I'm not there even
because of Any intrinsic quality about
Trump I'm there because of how corrupt
our political establishment and legal
establishment are that they would go
after Trump
as a little
wrench in the gears
Trump as this weird Outsider who kind of
broke the rules and they're going to try
to kill him for it they're going to try
to have the man die in prison for it and
I just I just don't like that very much
Trump for his party says he's never
going to leave interviewing Politico he
says I will never leave look if I would
have left I would have left prior to the
original race in 2016 that was a rough
one in theory that was not doable but
the and that's kind of funny Trump in
this quote uses the word that I've been
using all day long that was not
intentional that I've I've followed him
he said these are Thugs and degenerates
who are after me so so true
now the question for Republicans is do
do we just finally need an alternative
is that it does Trump just have too much
baggage are they just after him too hard
is there no way to overcome the attacks
on him do we need an alternative
Denis Denay Benton who is some Broadway
person gave us the answer to that
question the other night at the Tony
Awards when she referred to the number
two guy in the Republican race for
president
as uh I'll I'll let her put it in her
own words
[Applause]
earlier tonight
CMU and the Tony Awards presented the
2023 excellence in theater education
award and while I am certain that the
current Grand wizard I'm sorry excuse me
governor of my home state of Florida
sure that he will be changing the name
of this following Town immediately
we were honored to present this award to
the truly incredible
I think we can cut off Danae Benton okay
did you hear she called Ron DeSantis a
racist
wow what an amazing comedy routine what
what incisive humor that really allows
me to see Governor DeSantis in a new and
shocking light wow
boy that's it that's Showbiz for you
this reminds me of of uh back in the
Bush Administration Bush too Christopher
Hitchens who for all his problems was
pretty funny Christopher Richards goes
on the Bill Marsh show and Bill Maher
made a joke about how George Bush was
stupid and the audience started clapping
and before he said
George Bush is stupid and Chris richen
said it goes you know this is ridiculous
not one person in your audience is
smarter than George Bush he said George
Bush is a rather intelligent person and
the George Bush's stupid line is the
joke that stupid people laugh at
and the audience started booing him and
then he flipped them all off because he
didn't really care that's how I feel
here
ooh hey I gotta I got one for you ready
I'm gonna speak truth to power and be
really funny ready here we go
Republicans are racist
yeah okay so
regardless of what this says about the
Dems and the libs and the Showbiz people
this also tells you what the race is
going to look like no matter who gets
the nomination any
Republican who gets the nomination will
be Hitler
any Republican
it maybe you prefer Ron DeSantis right
now because you think DeSantis would be
a better nominee totally fair argument
great have that argument all day long
but if you prefer Ron DeSantis or any
other Republican because you think he's
clean and the Democrats aren't going to
hate him and the Democrats aren't going
to wield their massive political power
to convince the centrists and the
moderates and the squishy Libs to hate
him you are out of your mind
Ron DeSantis will be super duper Mega
Hitler
if he becomes the nominee
ASA Hutchinson will be super duper Mega
Hitler if he becomes a nominee
Donald Trump
is far from being the most extreme
obnoxious shocking terrible Fringe
candidate we've ever run he's one of the
most acceptable to the liberal hordes
that we've ever run as a Republican
Party
Donald Trump
was a network television star for 15
years Donald Trump was a member of New
York liberal Society for 40 years Donald
Trump was a tabloid star he was he was
wrapped of in hundreds of hip-hop songs
you do not get any more mainstream
acceptable to the liberal culture than
Donald Trump
and they turned him into Mega Hitler and
they're going to do the same thing to
anybody
notice it's not even that they said Ron
DeSantis is racist they said he's the
grand wizard of the Ku Klux Klan
okay
for years liberals have told us we need
to listen to the children and I've
always been a little skeptical of that
advice since children as a rule are
ignorant and irrational today however as
our ruling class is now more ignorant
and irrational still
I'd have to say that the kids are all
right especially the kids of Marshall
Simons Middle School in Burlington
Massachusetts
intolerance and homophobia are
unacceptable this type of intolerant
rhetoric starts in the home parents
angry at Town Hall over intolerance at
Marshall Simons Middle School kids were
asked to wear Rainbow clothes in honor
of Pride Spirit day but some organized a
counter protest wearing red white and
blue or black the principal sharing a
statement to families that Pride posters
were ripped down stickers ripped up some
students chanted USA are my pronouns and
students showing Pride were intimidated
it was an unruly disruption in fact that
was organized ahead of time while some
parents were upset others say it was
overblown some of the kids threw the
stickers on the ground but you know I
can only speak for my daughter she just
she didn't want to wear that to school
it's not that she wanted to hurt
anybody's feelings she says her daughter
felt coerced and participate in the
pride event and was offended by some of
the messages like this quote from
Tennessee Williams human heart cannot be
straighted as curves and wines and my
daughter just kind of said you know Mom
that's that's offensive to to me who I
am straight
yeah that flag is offensive to all
normal people it is a symbol of Pride
the deadliest of the seven deadly sins
it obviously has no place in a middle
school classroom this pushback offers a
glimmer of hope especially because this
incident did not take place in Tennessee
didn't take place in Texas it took place
in Burlington Massachusetts
12 miles outside of Boston
people have had enough
not just the stodgy old conservatives
the youths too not just the red States
but in Liberal towns in bright blue
counties in reliably Democrat States
we may or may not already be too far
gone the government might be too
unresponsive to the people only time
will tell
but for what it's worth today
all evidence shows that the American
people are becoming much more socially
conservative now speaking of Beverage
companies there's some great news that
has come out of Starbucks of all places
and there's great news on the pride
front but there's great news even on the
racial identity politics front it's
coming out of Starbucks
a company that I am I feel is now
somewhat Vindicated that I have defended
tepidly over the years Starbucks has
just gotten into trouble
among the libs because allegedly it it
ordered its stores to get rid of all the
Rainbow merch during pride month and
it's a little unclear Starbucks
Corporation is denying that they did
that but the Starbucks Union is saying
that they did in fact do that and
whatever I hope they did that something
I've long defended about Starbucks is
one it's a great Corporation they make
much better coffee than people give them
credit for they've essentially installed
bathrooms public bathrooms into every
major city in the world which I really
appreciate because previously it was
very hard to find a bathroom if you were
wandering around the city so I I they
make the pumpkin spice latte big
defender of that
but one thing Starbucks has done is they
seem very liberal without totally going
over to all the kind of liberal
craziness
for a while people accused Starbucks of
donating to Planned Parenthood that
wasn't really true they they agreed to
match employee donations to certain
non-profit organizations one of which
was planned parenthood even there it's
not like Starbucks was writing big fat
checks to Planned Parenthood you know as
a as a matter of corporate policy you
know to say we support abortion or
something like that but
putting the pride thing aside there's an
even better Story coming out of
Starbucks
a white Starbucks employee was just
awarded 25 million dollars over race
discrimination
a federal jury just awarded a white
Starbucks regional manager who was fired
after staff at one of her stores called
the cops on two black men who were
loitering in 2018.
they just awarded her over 25 million
because they found that Starbucks fired
her because of her race because she was
white this was not a an ambiguous ruling
it was a unanimous ruling
the court awarded her 25 mil in punitive
damages and 600 Grand in compensatory
damages
because Starbucks violated
Jersey Law and Title VII of the Civil
Rights Act
so true so good what happened here
well after that incident where there
were some black men who were sort of
loitering in the store and they weren't
really ordering anything and they were
ordered out and they wouldn't leave and
then finally someone called the cops on
them after that there were all sorts of
big exploitative racial grievance
protests and so Starbucks really wanted
to clamp down
and so this woman uh observed that
Starbucks started punishing white
employees
and and that or urged 175 000 employees
at 8 000 locations to undergo
sensitivity training would fire white
employees over very very minor issues if
those issues even occurred at all
whereas they would not fire employees of
other races so anyway
now this woman is Vindicated we need a
lot more of this
we need a lot more of this we need a lot
more of white people suing for
discrimination on the basis of race we
need a lot more of straight people
whatever you know like people who have
normal sexual views and identities and
and behaviors to sue on the basis of
sexual discrimination we need more
Christians to sue on the basis of
religious discrimination we need more
people of the politically disfavored
groups to wield the civil rights law
in our favor because right now civil
rights law is used as nothing more than
a cudgel
to attack politically disfavored groups
in this case men
people with ordinary sexual behaviors
white people Christians right
we need to wheel that in the other
direction it's it's unfortunate
that this is what it's come to but I
predicted this you know how much I hate
to say I told you so I predicted this
I said that with a constant
regime of racial identity politics it
was only a matter of time before white
people developed a racial Consciousness
white people uniquely among racial
groups do not have a racial
Consciousness there's a Pew survey that
we often point to which is
different racial groups were asked does
race matter to your sense of identity
and
for every racial group Asian Hispanic
and black
50 or higher of respondents said that
race mattered somewhat or very much to
their sense of identity for black people
it was over 70 percent
white people uniquely said it doesn't
matter to their sense of identity it's
15 percent
and a consequence of this has been that
white people have been
systematically discriminated against on
the basis of their race in college
admissions in Employment Practices like
we just saw out of Starbucks
throughout the culture it's not only the
only group that as a matter of law you
can discriminate against though to some
degree agents can be discriminated
against too but it is the only group
for whom it is socially acceptable and
even encouraged
to insult
to malign to diminish
and this is a bad situation this isn't
good for anybody
and the same thing is true for people
who have normal sexual behaviors and the
same thing is true for Christians on the
religious front we need a lot more of
this we need a lot more lawfare we need
a lot more wielding power there's
nothing principled about allowing your
uh political opponents radical leftists
in this case to wield the political
order to beat you into submission into
into into second class status
in your country nothing principled
nothing Noble about that
we need to engage in political reality
in a just and moral way
speaking of weird sex stuff scientists
have reportedly created synthetic human
embryos without sperm or egg that's not
great uh this uh according to a report
out now
[Music]
report says that the science the
scientists are referring to it as
synthetic embryos but these are not
truly synthetic in the sense that
they're not created from scratch they're
created from stem cells and
he said they're doing this because if
you want to understand really what's
going on as embryos develop normally or
when things go wrong earlier leading to
a miscarriage or certain congenital
disorders for example then people have
had to use embryos that are donated for
research which are left over after in
vitro fertilization so let me translate
that clinical gobbledygook into reality
people are giving their children over to
these quack doctors to poke and prod and
test things out on until they ultimately
destroy them the the embryos created for
in vitro fertilization are human beings
they're human persons who are created by
people who undergo an immoral process to
create
their babies and then a result of this
and I know a lot of people engage in
this process and a lot of them don't
even pay any thought to what the process
looks like they just think about their
children who come out at the end of this
process and they love their children and
so they say okay whatever it took to
create these children is worthwhile and
no you can value good ends of processes
without justifying the immoral means
that it took to get them and the immoral
means here is IVF and so they say when
we want to experiment on little tiny
babies little embryos we usually have to
do it by taking them from parents who
don't want the rest of their kids but
now now we get something even better
which is we can create these these human
embryos from scratch or almost from
scratch and then we can test things out
on them it reminded me of an article
I just saw in the daily wire three
thousand-year-old mummy offered as human
sacrifice discovered in Peru
you read that you say wow it's pretty
amazing how they know it was offered as
a sacrifice okay because maybe some of
the ritual stuff around it and that
crazy people used to have human
sacrifice and then you read stories
about weird Cults that still exist in
different parts of the world today and
some of which still practice human
sacrifice say man that's so weird we
live in modern fancy Society where we
have iPhones and stuff and and isn't
that crazy that in other primitive
societies they used to sacrifice human
beings and then you read stories like
that
like the scientist embryo story and you
realize oh right we still do that
in fact we we practice more human
sacrifice today than any people ever
throughout all of human history we
practice it through abortion which kills
about 800 000 little babies per year and
sacrifices them to the gods of career
and money and individuality and and we
also sacrifice little babies on the
altar of Science and progress and to to
give ourselves greater fortune and
health well we have to sacrifice the
babies we have to create these babies
and sacrifice these pure little babies
because then we might discover the cure
to an illness that affects us and maybe
we'll get to live for another six months
or six years who knows maybe a long time
we we keep we keep doing the same thing
and the reason we keep doing it is the
human nature never changes and the
reason that we don't even realize that
we're doing it is because human nature
never changes and it's very easy to
delude ourselves
about the the immorality of the things
that we engage in when we think that
we're going to get some kind of a
material benefit for it we've been doing
that for all of human history and we do
it still today and we we flatter
ourselves that we're so Advanced now
that we don't do it anymore we are so
Advanced now we're much more advanced
than these primitive tribes
and the scary part is the more advanced
we get
the more wickedness we engage in we can
also engage perhaps in more good but
when we engage in evil stuff we can do
so to a far greater degree than some
random tribesmen in
1000 BC Peru
speaking of Technology big Tech
Platforms in our dystopian future Elon
Musk CEO of Twitter and many other
platforms
and companies rather says that we need
to not fear the cyborg future
because the cyborgs are already here we
are already cyborgs according to Elon he
says we're already cyborgs our memory is
overwhelmingly outsourced to computers
they remember everything with extreme
Precision down to the pixel our thinking
is much less outsourced
as there are still many things we can do
that AI cannot for now
it's a really important Insight because
yes we're all afraid of the chip going
into our brain
getting plugged into the Matrix wearing
some stupid headset or whatever walking
around like robots but in many ways we
already are cyborgs
how much of your day do you spend like
this
looking up important information
communicating with people through this
it's true you just hold this phone
device in your hand
but it would it really be all that
different if the phone were just
stitched to your hand would your life
really be all that different how about
people who wear the eye watch how about
people well no one really wears those
stupid goggles yet but soon people will
how much of your day are you focused on
these things
and how much do you rely on them for and
what does that do to your Humanity I
remember when I was in high school I was
told that we are more knowledgeable than
Socrates that we today because we have
all this information at our fingertips
Socrates didn't have that aren't we're
smarter than Aristotle aren't we no of
course not we're much stupider than
Aristotle because as we've come to rely
on this technology we memorize things
less that's elon's point
and when we memorize things less
we just are less conscious this is why
it's really important I highly recommend
you take a moment memorize a poem
memorize some some lines of a play or
something like that it's a really
important exercise because then you'll
be able to recall information
when you encounter a work of art let's
say in a museum you see a guy in a hair
shirt eating bugs you you can know you
can remember that that is probably
referring to John the Baptist because
you've read something else you've read
the Bible and you've seen other works of
art you've actually engaged with this
yourself
the the alternative to that is we
Outsource all of our memorization and to
some degree we Outsource our thinking to
computers and then we just deprive
ourselves of culture and humanity and we
become basically nothing other than
consumers
which is what the ruling class wants us
to be
that's what the corporations want us to
be that's what our political Masters
want us to be that's what
that's what the people at the top want
us to be they want us to be mindless
consumers and this is something that's
pushed not just by the left it's also
pushed by the right
the right that has made an idol out of
say the free market and consumer Choice
the right that has put that cart before
the horse they've done that too
and I think
I think of when I have a moment free
what do I want to do I want I want to
smoke a cigar maybe I want to have a
drink maybe I also want to strum my
ukulele or play some other musical
instrument I also want to read a book I
also want to maybe paint I'm a very bad
painter but I kind of like doing it
and I don't even have that many hobbies
people used to have much more serious
Hobbies I have relatively few Hobbies
many people have fewer Hobbies even than
I do
and so what we become in that case is
just passive consumers
and I strongly suspect that the uptick
in depression the uptick in alienation
that people feel in society is because
of that because they're not engaged in
human Pursuits they're just consumers
and eventually we all just we just get
fat and lazy and tired and bored of the
things that we're watching everything
has a cost
streets man
[Music]